- Mille bouteilles remplies,
puis empaquetées toutes
les minutes : l'automatisation
règne en maître dans la nouvelle
brasserie de Molso
à Longueuil, construite au coût
de 525 millions de dollars.
FREDERIC LANDTMETERS,
pdg Molson Coors Canada
- Pour la petite histoire,
c'est aussi le plus gros
investissement que Molson Coors
a fait dans l'histoire récente
de l'entreprise au monde.
- D'ici sortent 230 millions
de litres de bière par année,
destinés presque exclusivement
au marché québécois.
Tout le génie réside
dans ce système d'entreposage
automatisé : 22 000 palettes
sont réparties sur huit étages.
L'automatisation a
un prix : l'entreprise passe
de plus de 500 employés
à 420 travailleur
Sur le front environnemental,
réunir le brassage et
l'entreposage sous un même toit
permet de réduire le transport
de marchandises.
TIM CREASE, dg brasserie
Molson Coors de Longueuil
- Notre utilisation d'énergie,
ici, à Longueuil, on parle
de 40 % de moins que la rue
Notre-Dame.
- Fini, les chambres froides
on les remplace par des cuves
frigorifiques, beaucoup moins
énergivores.
La magie de la fermentation
s'opère sous nos yeux.
Les recettes originales brassées
dans de l'équipement dernier cri
offrent le même goût d'antan...
ou presque.
VALERIE FRASER, maseuse
Molson Coors de Longueuil
- On est en mesure de sortir
plus de petites, petites
améliorations : un peu plus de
fruit daoors Light,
un peu plus d'arôme de houblon
dans notre Molson Export.
- Mais la soif croissante
des consommateurs pour la bière
en canettes ternit le bilan
environnemental du brasseur
bicentenaire. L'emballage en
aluminium, moins écologique que
les bouteilles réutilisables,
atteint maintenant 70 %
des ventes.
- Donc si le consommateur,
effectivme on l'a vu
au fil des dernières années,
demande plus de canettes, à nous
de voir comment la production
de ces canettes peut se faire
de façon plus efficace.
- L'usine d'un million de pieds
carrés repose sur un terrain
qui fait six fois sa superficie,
ce qui permettra à Molson Coors
d'augmenter la taille
de ses installations
et de sa production
e de la demande.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughes,
Radio-Canada, Lon